hey a special thanks to trends for
sponsoring a portion of this video
trends is the ultimate knowledge hub
from the hustle
it's a community built for entrepreneurs
founders investors
and ambitious people to gather learn
workshop
and collaborate trends gives you the
information
and network you need to be successful
it's a great place to jump start your
ideas and workshop with like-minded
builders i'm
soaking up the videos and the podcasts
from industry leaders who share their
wisdom and tips
the data on industries and business
models is an invaluable tool
i use to help me with my climate
campaign and the access to a community
of successful
business thinkers who are making it
happen in the world of commerce
today helps me imagine bigger
and better there's something here for
every business person
from startup to multi-million dollar
mogul
join the trans community today right now
you can get your first seven days for
just one dollar
go to trends dot co slash star talk
for your one dollar seven day trial
this is star talk i'm your host neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and this is a cosmic
queries edition
on a subject i think about which we all
care
or should care and that's the science of
happiness
and we got one of our happy co-hosts to
join me nagin farsad again welcome back
to star talk hi neil
i'm so happy to that's be happy face
you are host of the podcast fake the
nation and i recently appeared on that
podcast i enjoyed it thank you for
having me you killed it people still
write me about that episode
oh my god thank you thank you and you're
also the author of the
funniest book title i've ever seen as
well how to make white people laugh
for all people of color this should be
like at the top of their shelf right
because you don't want angry white
people that's some scary stuff is that
what you're saying
it's a useful quick reference guide and
you get to say that because your
heritage is not sort of european white
so what is your heritage
i'm i'm an iranian-american muslim like
everyone
yeah like everybody yeah yeah you left
out maybe two boxes you could have
checked there
all right so neither of us have
expertise on this so we bring in experts
when we need them and today we've got
our special guest
psychologist lori santos lori welcome to
star talk
thank you so much for having me on the
show excellent so you're a professor of
psychology up at yale in in new haven
connecticut
and you're head of silman college and
now just so people understand in the ivy
league and in many other places
dormitories are basically called
colleges is that correct
yeah it's kind of like hogwarts you know
they kind of steal from the harry potter
you know
slytherin yale is based on hogwarts okay
gotcha so ahead this is a title that if
i remember correctly
it was once called the master of
stillman college so i guess
that went out with the with the movement
this
in the summer of 2020 right you can't
run around calling people master
yeah exactly especially since you know
many of the heads of college are
white men and you know a lot of our
students or students of color
it gets a little awkward and at one time
they maybe actually own slaves
not this round but earlier generations
possibly
so what do you do so you are the
director of the
comparative cognition laboratory at yale
and is
in particular the canine cognition
center
so that's just fancy talk for dogs right
that's exactly right yeah
we're really interested in what makes a
human mind special that's kind of my day
job when i'm not studying happiness and
well-being is this question of
what makes the human mind unique and we
study dogs in part because
we built them to be a lot like us and so
if we're expecting some critters out
there to show
human-like characteristics it's probably
going to be dogs let's let's
i want to hear you say that again we
invented dogs just say that
well we didn't really invent them but
you know we shape them
you know they're a lot different than a
wolf you know most of us wouldn't be
kind of curling up in the bed with the
wolf you know
hey speak for yourself
that's why nagin only has three limbs
the wolf got hungry overnight so you
also host the podcast happiness lab
this is a great title pushkin industries
are they the sponsors of the lab is that
uh sponsors of the podcast yeah the
podcast sorry good
okay well well excellent so let me just
ask some general questions just to start
out here
so um isn't happiness
i don't mean to get sound all
philosophical but how do you
know you're happy unless at some time
you felt sad
yeah i mean i think one thing to know
about happiness is i wish we had a more
scientific
approach to it right language that's why
you're that's why we have you
this is why we're trying right but even
though you have lots of researchers
studying happiness we don't have great
measurement tools for happiness right i
wish we had a little happiness
thermometer that we could stick in
people's mouths and know
oh you know combining all their emotions
of joy and laughter and sometimes
anxiety here's their happiness reading
right by the way there's a great quote i
think it was logan clendening
if not him it was someone of his ilk
that said no science achieves maturity
without a system of measurement and so
this is one of the things that happiness
researchers
have been working on for a while now we
have actually like two two decades worth
of data looking at this
and what they've converged on which
sounds not scientific but actually is is
quite a good measurement is simply
asking people about their own happiness
now when i first started this right i
study animals for a living my
my work is in animal cognition where we
have these really strict measurements
that come out of the history
of ethology and things like that what is
it
uh ethology is sort of the study of
animal behavior and things right
that's a word i didn't think that's
where you told me a word
did you know this word i have never
heard of this word
ethology the the study of animal
behavior
and animal uh kind of communication okay
so the people who study
ethics that it's not ethology i guess
yeah i guess that's
ethics ethics i'm sorry
go on continue yeah yeah so the point is
that i was when i first
got to this work on the science of
well-being and i saw that you know great
studies were based on asking people
about their own happiness i was pretty
worried
but what i realized was two things first
is that these measurements are actually
pretty solid right they tend to be
measurements that are
relatively valid so we can kind of like
measure them over and over again
and they also be tender repeatable
they're repeatable right you know just
like we really want in science obviously
we measure you twice we get the same
kind of reading you know time one time
two
but the other thing is that these
measurements seem to correlate with all
kinds of things that we think
must be relevant for happiness so when
we have good hormonal measures of
people's moods
people's self-reports of how they're
feeling correlate with that people
self-reports of how they're feeling
whether they're happy or not also
correlate with like
rich textual analysis of their journals
you know so i grab your diary
and i do all this machine learning on
the adjectives you use and that
really hardcore analysis correlates with
when i ask you you know all things
considered scale of one to ten how
satisfied are you with your life and so
in a bunch so one of the
things you listed there was you say
hormones but we can just broaden that
and say
chemistry you're saying if you say
you're happy that correlates with
being chemically happy that's right i
mean the problem is that
we don't know a lot about what chemical
happiness looks like because even
yeah it's called marijuana
psilocybin
but no but even even those kinds of
measurements are hard when we don't know
what happiness is right because if i
measure your chemicals and or i give you
marijuana say and then i ask
then i have to measure did the marijuana
make you happy but i'm still at square
one i have to ask you hey are you happy
now after you you know smoked up a bit
and so so so but but what the science
suggests is these relatively valid
measurements might be tapping into the
real thing we want to measure
which is i don't want to know about your
hormones i don't want to know about your
chemistry i want to know
how you feel right now you know you know
on a scale of one to ten how are you
feeling so in some sense if you tell me
on a valid measurement that you're
feeling pretty good that's kind of what
i want to maximize with any intervention
i'm gonna do
on how you're feeling right i want you
to think that you're feeling
as a psychologist this is a very
important goal
yeah i mean you know especially you know
you and i are talking right now in the
midst of covin 19 you know right after
2020 this has been a really hard
a really hard year and a really hard
time a lot of people are feeling
you know much more depressed and anxious
and uncertain and lonely than they felt
in a really long time and so
if we could find good interventions that
work across people's individual
differences to boost up their well-being
we'd be doing something really good for
the world but can you translate it
into like cups or quartz
or like milliliters for people who don't
like the king's measurements
is there can i get like some just easy
because i want to bake it you know what
i mean
what i can tell you is that social
scientists are interested in two aspects
of happiness that's what people tend to
measure
um so one of those aspects is sort of
how you feel
in your life right which is the kind of
emotions you have we don't want to get
rid of negative emotions because that's
you know part of a rich fulfilling life
but we want on average there to be more
like laughter and joy and positive
things than you know anger and sadness
and
you know anxiety and things right by the
way lori when i when i was growing up i
grew up in new york city
and so i had exposure to theater right
just as a new york resident it's just
part of the life
of of growing up there and
i remembered seeing these this pair
icon of a smiley face and a sad face
and i thought why is there a sad face
there oh because theater takes you both
places i say
why ever take someone to a sad i just
did not
understand why you would glorify making
someone sad
in what you wrote why is this and i i
could i was a
full i might have been 40 before i came
any
sense an understanding of this so so
that's kind of back to my
early question what role in value does
depression play i don't mean clinical
depression but just i have a bad day i
feel sad
tomorrow i feel great because i've been
to l.a and the freaking sun is out every
day and it's 72 degrees and a little
cloud comes and says oh it's a cloudy
day
it's like shut up you have no idea what
anything other than a sunny day is like
because and so they're sad because they
started in a whole other place
so how does that factor into all of this
well there's kind of two reactions that
so one gets to the other kind of measure
of happiness so i said the first one is
how you're feeling in your life but then
there's a second
thing i really want to maximize which is
how you're feeling with your life
you know that's the answer to the
question how satisfied are you with your
life right now
and those two things like how you're
feeling right now whether you're happy
joyous sad whatever
and how satisfied you are with your life
those those things can vary a little bit
right
you know i think you know sometimes when
we're doing our best work when we're
getting the most meaning out of life you
know i think back to grad school when i
was like feeling really fulfilled
career-wise
those in the moment weren't necessarily
the best times you know
um my dean who lives with me in the
college right now she and her wife have
a new baby
and they're kind of in the midst of this
too you know they're so satisfied with
their life you know they brought this
life into the world it's so meaningful
but day to day it kind of sucks like not
sleeping dirty dying
that's bad news right and so so i think
you can have these dissociations right
so it's important to measure both
kind of in general in a big picture way
how satisfied are you what meaning do
you have you know do you have a sense of
purpose
and also kind of in the trenches are you
mostly feeling good again we're not
trying to get rid of negative emotion
but the goal is that when you're having
it you're learning from it or it's
serving a purpose or it stands in
contrast to some other kind of emotion
that you have
you also study you also study dog brains
and all the people who have what do they
call the
the the dog they carry on airplanes with
them
emotional support animals thank you
thank you the emotional
support negan i saw a comedian i forgot
which one i think it was
sebastian martin maniscalco thank you
for
um where he said he saw
he saw the actor who played superman
carrying
an emotional support dog onto the plane
he said no
we have to stop somewhere neal you
haven't
you haven't seen my emotional support
wolf on the airplane
that's where things get interesting it's
how to make everyone scared so you feel
better about yourself
[Laughter]
so if you study dog brains the the
soothing effect that
that a that a very comforting dog can
have
i guess there's some kind of symbiosis
there right yeah most of the work that
we do in the dog lab is a bit separate
from the happiness work but there is a
growing body of work about
what's called human animal interaction
right just this idea of kind of
socially connecting with this other
creature that seems not judgmental maybe
not even as judgmental as some of your
friends or some of your family members
like it can be a powerful i hope not
right you hope not yes
you look terrible this morning
my dog did not like this outfit you guys
and
uh it was a tough one
no but what they're tapping into is one
of the
necessary features for happiness which
is some form of social connection
ideally we're getting that with other
homo sapiens right
but you know if that's not happening
then sort of having a non-judgmental
connection with the animal
can give us a lot of the same pleasures
that we get out of connecting with other
humans too
and before we go to the break because we
haven't gotten to any questions yet and
again i assume you have questions lined
up
oh my god out there right right so
what about i don't want to derail where
we're going here but
i i can't help but think about emotional
support robots
either for people who can't interact
with other humans
which is a big part of what you're
describing you know people on the autism
spectrum are not
all in on that but but a robot
might provide that so what about robot
happiness yeah there's actually lots of
work trying to use
you know soft fuzzy cuddly kind of
almost animalistic robots
um as kind of emotional support critters
for
individuals on the spectrum but i think
it doesn't have to be individuals on the
spectrum you know i think in covet 19
i've seen lots of tweets of like the
last person i talked to was my roomba
you know like a lot of people okay
if you make furry rumbas that'll change
the whole
ecosystem by the way my therapist told
me
uh because i not to brag but i've
experienced some anxiety in my life
and um my therapist had me uh pet my dog
meaningfully
for like a few minutes every night to
like help bring down my anxiety
so why are you bragging where's the
bragging in that um
anxiety is a very elite uh experience
everyone has experienced it did
you know in general a lot of those
things that that a lot of the questions
actually
are going to touch on um a lot of stuff
that she talked that she had me do
um have helped with my anxiety
so wait a minute negine you just solved
something lori let me get your fast
opinion before we go to break
the the james bond villains who are
always
petting a cat on their left they have
high anxieties
you need a monocle and you need a dog or
a cat
and you need to do having some nice
petting motions
you can be as evil as you want but also
calm
excellent so let's take a quick break
and when we come back we're going to
blow right through
uh our cosmic queries on the science of
happiness
with the lori sometimes when we return
we're back star talk cosmic queries a
topic which is on all of our minds
especially coming out of the
co-vidiverse the coronavers it's the
science of happiness and lori santos
this is your
one of your professional specialties is
thinking about this as a psychologist
and professor up at yale
i say up at yale because we are in new
york city and that's north and so
up is north that's what i mean by that
for those who have no clue or don't
really care what that means
so laura you have a podcast that means
you probably also have a twitter handle
and
or an instagram handle what are they i
do i'm on twitter i'm just my name at
lori santos and you can check out the
podcast the happiness lab anywhere you
download your podcasts okay excellent
very good okay so nagin you got
questions for us called from our fan
base
oh my god laura you got so many amazing
questions and the first
one is so that's that's code for saying
when you answer keep it short
um so this first question comes from
patreon from augusta
suresh uh in sorry if i mispronounced
that name
uh in a recent episode of star talk dr
tyson mentioned that he chose to have
comedians on the show because if people
smile and enjoy the moment they are more
likely to remember it
can you give us some scientific insight
on how happiness can lead to stronger
memories
i love that question also as a comedian
i especially love it
it also puts you on the spot and
if we don't laugh you're gone
you know but leah please give me reason
for being laurie
please yeah can we justify nagin's
existence
yeah yeah definitely i mean well one
thing is like you know people remember
the things that they're talking about
because jokes are funny right and funny
things are the kinds of things you want
to share
right you know so if they hear a good
joke on star talk they're going to want
to tell their friends or get their
friends to listen to the podcast so they
can hear it too
but we also know that memory that's the
spreading of love the spreading
spreading of love yes sharing
star talk with your friends full
spreading of love right there that
increases happiness
but also we know that memories really
require some emotional experience right
it helps us tag
kind of the things in life you know if i
asked you what are some of your earliest
memories from childhood my guess is that
they're tinged with like
strong affect or strong emotion you know
that time you got lost at the grocery
store and you were scared or that time
you got the present you wanted and you
were super happy right
those are the things that tend to stick
out and so you know if we want to make
things memorable
you know giving someone a pleasure a
pleasurable experience is a really good
way to do it
so negan you didn't grow up in new york
city but i did
and it's i don't know if it's still a
thing
but the most terrifying prospect
okay is getting lost in macy's
okay i haven't heard much lately but
when i was growing up
that was the thing because we've all
been to macy's is the single largest
store in the world at herald square it's
where the
parade ends and they dance that frontage
is an entire
block it's a whole universe and it's
it's it's nine floors up and
the floor is down yes it is it's the
macy's universe
and you're in there like holding your
parents hand and
you just you worry that if they just let
go and it's always so crowded and so
many people and you're little
so that was a fear factor i just want
you to it's also like it's like the
vatican it has
its own like it's its own nation it has
its own
girls
and for some reason you always walk out
with like three extra handbags
and you smell like 12 different types of
perfume a lot happens at macy's
but i like that that you need an
emotional connection and so what you're
saying
lori is that laughter and joy is an
emotional connection to the learning but
you're also saying that nagin could also
make us angry and have the same effect
consequences that might other other
consequences for star talk you know
we want this show to be memorable but
not you know anger but not in that angry
okay so negan don't piss us off okay
uh well that's when i bring out the wolf
so yeah as long as that
he's he's in the you know um
should we go into another question yeah
keep going keep coming so this is from
um it's uh also from patreon
uh it's uh 12 and a half year old
astrophysicid
violetta writing in from birmingham
um professor santos is there any
scientific truth to the statement
ignorance is bliss does processing more
general knowledge
make us more or less content i love
this question this is a question badass
question from a 12 year old
astrophysicist
i'd be bad ass from an adult
so it's double badass coming from
somebody who's still in their tweens
okay yeah yeah well you know i mean
socrates said that you know the
unexamined life is not worth living
right and i think he was kind of i think
he was sort of on to something in a
certain way i mean
one thing that we know is that there's a
lot of happiness boost that comes with
learning something new especially
learning something new
in a challenging way one of the coolest
concepts in positive psychology is this
concept
of flow this time when you're kind of so
entrenched in something that you're like
losing track of time
and it can happen in lots of like sports
activities and things but it can also
happen
when you're learning something really
well that's called being in the zone
right exactly being in the zone but
that's the kind of thing that can happen
when we're
learning something challenging you know
if you're doing like a hard math problem
that's like taking all of your cognitive
energy but you can still do it it's not
like
so devastating that you kind of again
that happens to you all the time when
you're doing the problem
i'm doing a calculus theorem right on
the side right here you guys can't see
it
or even a hard puzzle you know like like
a good jigsaw puzzle that's like taking
all your attention right
and i think that's a sign that when
we're learning especially when we're
learning
right at the edge of our ability that is
something that our brains
tag as joyful is so immersive where does
the phrase ignorance of bliss come from
i think the phrase ignorance is bliss
comes from when you're getting
bad information that you might not want
to know i mean i think this is something
you know if you find out some
terrible factoid or your friends were
talking about you or you learned some
awful truth like
that can kind of stick with you right
and so i think that's where the
ignorance is bliss comes from
but i would say you know maybe ignorance
is bliss but learning is definitely
bliss too so yeah can i can i push back
as someone who knows nothing um then you
can't push back you can only just
raise your hand there's no pushing here
i don't know anything but i'm gonna push
back no those don't go together
in a sentence okay um okay so
the the i one of the things that has
reduced my
kind of like general unhappiness and
which has made me more happy
is turning off the notifications on my
phone i used to get
all the news notifications all the time
and so
not knowing things when they're
happening i have found to be
particularly blissful
oh yeah but you built in you know you
will learn it later
so it's just a delay right it's not a
total abject
ignorance right and that's one of the
reasons i mean so another thing that
really
we require for happiness in some sense
is the ability to attend
to notice stuff to be in the present
moment and one of the reasons that
notifications suck away our happiness so
much is they steal us out of that
you know i might be in the middle of
watching you know like like doing a
really great puzzle and like looking at
the pieces
or learning something new and then i
hear like bing like you know some
facebook friend posted some dumb thing
about politics
and now my brain is sucked out of that
moment that was giving it joy
and i'm kind of like wait what happened
and it takes me a while to get back
um one of the things we don't realize is
how much
these attention grabbers are negatively
affecting our happiness even if the
information we're getting is good
and so one quick happiness inducing
strategy you can do is to shut off lots
of those
non-urgent notifications on your phone
as soon as possible
it'll keep you more in the moment and
that being in the moment will boost your
well-being a bit
well which i'm old enough older than
both you all to remember
when it was policy for the medical
doctor to not tell you
that you were diagnosed with terminal
cancer they sew you back and so you're
fine
you're fine don't tell grandpa don't
tell and there was this even fact
i think as a cat on a hot tin roof the a
major running theme in that
is that the big daddy i think is has
cancer and he's i'm fit as a fiddle and
everyone knows he's about to die
so who was giving that advice at the
time
did medical doctors need more
psychologists to come in and run the
show
yeah it's tricky that's actually one
where you know ignorance might be a
little bit more
blissful or a specific kind of ignorance
which is you know one of the problems
that comes with knowing about your
medical diagnoses is that
in addition to doctors telling you more
information they also give you more
choice
right you find out some bad information
and the doctor says okay do you want
this kind of treatment or this one
and the research shows that another
thing that can be a real hit in our
well-being something we don't expect
is actually having too many choices too
many choices too many choices
so which is shocking right you know if
you give me a choice hey do you want
netflix where you have three movies or
do you want
netflix where you have like netflix
number of movies i would choose the
netflix number of movies right
that number is infinity just in case you
wondered yeah but haven't you all had
the same experience where you plop down
and you say all right i'm going to watch
a movie and it's
scroll scroll scroll and then my husband
comes in he's like you've been here for
like a half hour like scrolling
hour or later right right and you
finally get to the end of the scroll and
they've made
new movies to add to the list never mind
that i just found out there are 14
flavors of triscuits on the market now
and i found that to be very stressful
i mean you can't have too many snack
options it's uh demoralized
jello invented that okay jello a wall of
jello flavors
um so so lori what you're saying is the
high school senior who says
oh i got into 15 universities and i
don't know which one i'm sad
it's like you just want to punch him out
but he might be onto some
i mean what the data suggests is more
choices make you sad
and even when you do choose that you
have more regret
right you know if you had 50 colleges to
choose from and you pick one you're kind
of like
maybe one of those other 49 might have
been pretty good and so
i worry about this with so much you know
we have so much choice in
movies we have so much choice in dating
partners look at tinder right you know
but i
met my husband before online dating was
a huge thing and i think
you know i love him a lot well wait
nagin that could that could have
happened in
that sentence you know i met my husband
before
tinder you know people can't see my
video now but they're thinking she must
be
old for people who can't see her
she's sepia toned she looks very
old-timer
the edges are kind of afraid of the
image
okay so what you're saying is you
selected your husband from a
smaller pool of choices yeah one that
didn't feel infinite right and i think
that you know
people on the dating market this can get
depressed again this isn't
one of the themes of the of the work and
happiness and i talk about a lot of my
podcast is that our minds lie to us
about
what makes us happy a lot right you know
we think we want more choices if we had
to pick we'd pick something with lots of
choices but in fact that makes us
kind of unhappy you know we in another
is in our leisure you know we're just
talking about flow and picking things
that are challenging
if you give people a choice many people
will choose like easier problems or
something that's not as challenging
especially when they're kind of choosing
leisure
but in fact we kind of enjoy it when
puzzles are kind of tricky and hard i
think this is why so many people
gravitate towards astrophysics is
because you know we don't have
answers and actually people sort of like
that stuff when we i kind of like
being steeped in ignorance but i just
have to make it clear
on this podcast that you have told your
husband
darling i love you even though i had
fewer choices at the time
we got together just and and i've
justified that by my own research
i'm happy i'm happier for the limited
pool you were in
wait but this really makes a lot of
sense because i did do a lot of tinder
dating and i did do a lot of okcupid
dating
and but i had really strict rules so i
didn't get overwhelmed by the options
like i would only allow myself to like
browse for a certain number of minutes i
only reached out to people who i reached
out to i never responded to people who
thought they were interested in me
because they were always wrong
uh and so is your husband a product of
tinder and then the hilarious thing is
even though i was very successful
doing the online dating um and i had
like multiple boyfriends from that
my husband was an irl we met up like we
had the same acting coach
so it was a real showbiz connection wow
yeah okay
all right just wondering there okay well
give me some more questions
so we um also uh from patreon woody asks
is there a difference between
beers by a campfire happiness and
holding your newborn child for the first
time happiness
or is happiness just an out of ten
scoring system
wow i like that yeah well i think if you
get back to the definition of happiness
we talked about before where has these
two components like happiness in your
life and happiness with your life
you might get some differences there on
the you know beer by the campfire versus
newborn baby right newborn baby
hopefully they're cute and they're
cuddly and you're really excited and
happy
but you're probably the parents not just
the parents yeah the parents
your baby right you're a newborn baby
right cute but
but you know a lot of complicated
emotions uncertainty maybe some fear and
anxiety definitely lots of exhaustion
and so on right
but with the how you're feeling in your
life oh my gosh so much meaning of the
holding the new baby
you know around the campfire that kind
of feels good and that's great you know
feeling good and having some beers and
it's warm and fuzzy and social
connection that's all great
you know but that might not be
contributing as much to the meaning side
and so
when i think about maximizing my own
happiness i kind of want to bump up both
you know i want
joy and good feelings in my life but i
also want to make sure that they're
serving a bigger purpose
and a lot more meaning in my life too so
if i were to layer some math on this i
would say then that
the the axis of happiness
that is the inner fulfillment
is not the same axis as the one that's
happiness in the moment
and so to combine those you want to move
along both axes
to get some combination of both that
might be perfect for yourself
that's a fair way to think about it i
think that's exactly right i mean you
can definitely point to
people who have you know every comfort
and happiness on the in their life
kind of thing right you know like you
know rich folks who are you know social
media folks who have the best wine and
the best food and you know mm-hmm
on the yeah they feel empty you know
they feel empty right and they you know
report feeling lonely and so on so so
yeah so you want to kind of move up both
that
both you want to move up the line at
once maximizing yeah so you're basically
what you're both saying is
you should have more beers and more
babies
translate all of
okay we're gonna take a quick break and
we'll come back with
more cosmic queries the science of
happiness
we're back star talk cosmic queries the
science
of happiness happiness
and nadine you're taking us through
these questions but we got to go into
lightning round
uh for lori so lori lightning round
means we want one word answers to these
questions
okay can you can you do that i'm on it
you're totally on it okay
all right let's go okay here we go from
patreon gordon asks
hello uh what does science say about the
relationship between happiness and
lifespan and happiness and money i'm
from asia and my culture believes money
brings happiness
wow and just is that gordon does gordon
have a last name sorry gordon voo
gordon okay excellent so yeah i'd like
that
do happy people live longer happy people
do live longer
and happy people are wealthier in other
words uh you there are some studies that
show that if i measure your cheerfulness
at 18
that predicts how much money you're
going to be making in your 20s your late
20s and your 30s
so they're related they're correlated
but the the causal link seems to go
backwards we think when you get rich
you get happy but the data seem to
suggest if you're happy
then you might have lots of other stuff
that get you to be higher salaried and
stuff
or people like having you around and
then opportunities
are greater exactly maybe you're more
creative so you're better on the job and
so
so we kind of have it backwards well so
when i was in
high school i had friends who'd
nicknamed me chuckles
because i was always making jokes and
and having fun
so i had a nickname of chuck in in in
high school
so but i didn't become a comedian negan
i locked
did i go no i don't know what happened
to you along that way
because you do seem like you could have
naturally gone into disappointing
yeah damn i mean you know what i think
you ended up okay
[Laughter]
all right good answer so keep them
coming negin from instagram
uh nick doorfinger sorry from instagram
nickdorflinger asks
what drug gets me there safest
edgy question but i wonder yeah lori why
worry about
stuff in your life if you could just do
it chemically come on yeah
well the most legal drug i think is
gratitude
the best illegal drug probably
psilocybin is what the data suggests
um you you get a boost and a real kind
of connection with other people and
everything in the world and the data
seems to suggest that even once the drug
wears off
some of that connection still holds lots
of new like this is like
super ongoing research stuff right now
but the data suggests that work is going
to be super interesting in five
so does psilocybin have a street name uh
it's basically like just like taking
acid or like it's kind of like it's it's
like a bunch of
like psychedelics basically mushrooms
and stuff as well
exactly yeah cause i can't imagine
someone saying hey you want some
psilocybin you know
generally drug dealers don't use the
chemical name generally
lots of forms of psychedelics basically
psychedelics okay okay
right write that down nearly down okay
this next question is really close to my
heart
melanie montz in on instagram asks why
do we get depressed when we're not able
to socialize with our friends this
happens to me
what's up with that totally i mean
there's one of the most famous papers
published papers in the history of
social psychology suggests
that that social connection being around
other people physically being around
other people
is a necessary condition for high
happiness that was like the big tagline
of this paper
and so you're just like you know showing
off human nature that social connection
is
really required for high happiness now
this is tough during covet because we
have to get very creative about how we
get our social connection
and often involve screens like the one
you and i are talking over now
but the great news is it suggests most
of the connection we get
in real life we can get across the
screen too
so communication is what is really
happening there right
which is a fundamental part of what it
is to be human that we can communicate
information
yeah and we're social primates right you
know if we if we got one thing from our
primary ancestry it's the fact that
we like being around other critters and
grooming them and sort of getting
information from them
so it's not such a surprise that now
right because because negan pulls lice
off of her husband's hair
eats it don't you do that the grooming
you groom him this way don't you
no of course and it's delicious
and high in protein right okay another
another question
um from uh aloe alex10
uh from on instagram asks does happiness
fall under schedules of reinforcement or
is it innate
ah that's a good one and that implies a
certain dichotomy that those things are
are different um i guess i would say
there's some
there's research suggesting that some
aspects of our happiness are heritable
in other words there's some
maybe genetic or epigenetic components
to our happiness
but there's also lots of research
suggesting that you can build in your
own happiness that through your own
habits things like
being more social taking time for
gratitude taking time to be in the
present moment
even if you're kind of naturally like 5
out of 10 on a happiness scale
you can probably move it up through your
own behaviors to like
8 out of ten but you have to want to do
that you have to want to do that
and you have to put in the work right i
mean that's one of the messages is like
you can just like all good things like
you know being fit
you know learning astrophysics you can
do it but it's gonna
take some time and some energy one of my
favorite lines in ferris bueller's day
off
is when ferris bueller is describing his
best friend who's always miserable
so he says of his best friend cameron i
don't understand him
he's only happy when he's sad
and when i first heard i said what when
i said oh my gosh these are people who
go out of their way to put themselves in
a sad place
and that somehow seems to be their
equilibrium point
so so there are those who are five on
your scale who want to boost it but
maybe there are those
who are five who are just happy staying
happy at five
yeah i mean i definitely get most of the
emails i get asking questions about
happiness
are you know my spouse my child you know
someone in my life
is so unhappy what can i do to make them
happier
um and and the answer is you know
there's lots of stuff
they can do to make do become happier if
they put in the work but they kind of
have to want to do it
wow so what you're saying is you we
don't we don't have as much power as we
believe we have
over making someone else happy well we
do i think i mean i think one
honestly a strange thing one thing we
can do that's quite powerful
is to make ourselves happy one of the
another big powerful effect in this
field of positive psychology is the
power of emotional contagion
you know we we are chameleons we suck up
the emotions of other people
that's why people listen to star talk
right and hear you and the comedians
laughing right and they're
probably getting a little joy out of
that themselves even if they weren't
feeling it before
and so you know i often tell people you
would have to use the word contagion to
describe it
okay is there another word you can use
it seems like
it works i mean it's a tough word in a
pandemic neil yeah yeah
fair enough fair enough most pandemic
words are
i was going to say infectious but then
no again infectious
pandemic happiness right um but but
also is it unethical lori this is a
question um to slip
like a teaspoon of psilocybin to the one
you love
i'm pretty sure that's against the law
most places
but in the happiness universe it is
completely ethical yeah
for sure okay let's get another one we
have another question
from uh amy mccormick on instagram can
you explain the science behind seasonal
affective disorder
yeah i mean yeah sad seasonal affective
disorder
is is just part of the many
environmental things that affect our
happiness so we were just talking about
one right being around other people that
are happy
can make you a little bit happier but
we're really affected by our environment
and many of us are really affected by
light right just the sheer amount of
light that you get in we're also
affected by
kind of walks outside in nature there's
this wonderful japanese concept of
forest bathing where you go out in the
forest and it's thought of as a big
booster for your happiness but there's
some empirical evidence suggesting that
simply getting outside
and being around nature can be a really
powerful boost for happiness but why
does light
matter i mean i i say that only because
all right the sun doesn't
you know in different parts of the world
have very different amounts of sunlight
all right and winter nights can be very
long in the northern and very southern
climate southern south of the equator of
course because it's
symmetric in six months shifts so
so what i don't understand is when you
come indoors there's lights everywhere
yeah you turn on the lights we don't
we're not walking around with candles
you have like you know halogen bulbs not
anymore we have very
bright um leds so why does the sun
matter at all you're such an
astrophysicist to be defending darkness
right now by the way
it was dark for so long the light
doesn't even get here that fast
thank you see yeah no no but i think so
i think a couple things one is we can
fake it right you know this is one of
the treatments for seasonal affective
disorders to just
get yourself some light and make sure
you're surrounded by light
but another reason we that the
wintertime affects us so badly if you're
in the northern hemisphere that is right
is that you tend to behave differently
you know think of the number of social
connections you make in the summer
think of how much like nature bathing
you do in the summer when you're walking
around outside
what happens when it's cold out and it's
dark you know it's me in front of a
screen
right you know not paying attention to
you know my health right and so i think
it's partly the light but it's a lot our
behaviors
that depend on different light states
gotcha okay so that's a
that's a factor that's not otherwise
described because
it's saying is just light but you got a
whole matrix
of elements that plug into that which
make much more sense to me
and this is this is the big problem of
human you know human behavior you know i
wish as a psychologist we have
you know we talked about that people
talk about physics envy or astrophysics
yep it's there because you guys can't
isolate your
your videos anything you know i'd love
to be able to put somebody in a box and
be like okay you get this amount of
light versus this amount of light
and not mess up their emotion levels by
having them inside a box but they're
people
her husband is still in a box yeah
around the corner
that just how come why do we only see
lori but not her husband
where is that this is real shady lori
this is shady to be fair he's actually a
mit physicist so you know
he puts up with my physics envy in a
different way
all right give me some more and again
okay so from um the handle tyrell nikon
on instagram
are there long-term scientific methods
to generating happiness
this is the quintessential question
actually from yeah i'd like that because
long term implies i don't need to be
happy just in this moment because i had
a great meal
give me something that really i can
translate to my life
span yeah and so i think the biggest
ones are
gratitude so taking time to count your
blessings all kinds of evidence that
gratitude in the moment and in the long
term can really help you right
sort of forming a habit about gratitude
social connection is that the same thing
as
uh um when all else fails lower your
expectations people think that grateful
people are more like
resigned of like oh i'm so grateful i'm
not going to change the situation
it turns out great i'm grateful that i
have two legs you know no
can you can you up the bar around that a
little you know yeah
what's the evidence so grateful people
tend to be
uh more interested in changing the
status quo it's kind of like you have
some emotional resilience so you're like
i can put in the work to do things
this comes out a lot one big question i
get when i talk about gratitude with my
students who are very interested in
social justice and things
you know they often ask like well if i'm
grateful then i won't you know
fight for the changes that we want to
see in the world and that evidence
suggests the opposite when you're
grateful that's when you work really
hard right because you have some
emotional resources to help people who
are not yourselves
right you know forget about that because
you're going to make a change you got to
reach into yourself for
in your fuel tank right and start
applying that emotional energy
to to affect change that's interesting
exactly very cool
all right again we had time for maybe
one and a half more questions
okay give it to me um so sarah's style
asks on instagram do we want to be happy
or do we need to be happy is it
luxury or a survival i love it oh my
gosh
remember yes i think i think need to be
happy
happiness affects our immune function
happiness affects our longevity
happiness affects how we interact with
other people
uh my students sometimes joke that
happiness is a first world problem but
all the data suggests that happiness
matters more matters for the
fundamentals
um okay okay very good keep going negan
um and then uh you started to answer
this one but there this question kind of
came up a lot
from edxona on instagram can we fool
ourselves into being
happy can we convince our brain into
releasing dopamine you mentioned
gratitude is there another trick
yeah other tricks are having more social
connection being around other people
more
another easy one are like healthy habits
like exercise and sleep
one study shows that ex a half hour of
cardio can
reduce symptoms of depression as well as
one of the leading anti-depression
medications
and then a final one is presence just
try to be in the present moment like
notice what is happening in your body
right now follow your breath
it sounds kind of cheesy and hippie
dippy but the data suggests it can
really boost well-being
yeah science can support hippies there's
nothing no law against that right
sometimes they're right
they're reading the latest scientific
journals well
let me let me end with one i'll take
host rights and end with a question here
so if um let's say
i'm fabulously rich and i have servants
and i
sleep in the most comfortable bed all
and i can detect if there's a pee
underneath the bed uh like the princess
and the pee and then i have to
sleep on a cot okay and i'm miserable
meanwhile is a homeless person who's
been sleeping under a an
overpass and then you put them in a
cotton
oh my gosh this is comfortable so
it seems to me you cannot speak of
happiness
on absolute terms it's always going to
be just
relative to the person and if there's no
such thing as an absolute scale
then how do you sink your teeth into
what is
and is not true in what you study yeah i
think one thing to know is that's
definitely true
everything we know about happiness
suggests that it's relative it's
relative to where we were before it's
also a lot relative to other people so
one of the worst things you can do for
your happiness is look at
lots of happy people on instagram or
social media that makes you compare
yourself
oh there it is there's a word for that
what do they call that the
the the it's the uh social comparison
i know okay but i'm thinking yeah
which which affects you emotionally but
the whole point is that those things
it's not happiness in the universe not
being objective it's for me it can be
very objective for me i have my one to
ten scale
you know and as i go up you know if i
get more luxuries in life
then going back down to the cot might
make me feel kind of crappy
um but the key is that what you want to
be having is positive changes for
yourself and so
another kind of happiness tip is you
know not to always have the best things
in life you know when you start flying
first class every single time
that one time that there's no seat
available and you have to go and coach
you know your hate in life right yeah
but if you just occasionally
with high variance get the first class
that's a way to kind of boost up your
happiness so
there's a there's a mantra called split
your gains and combine your losses
in in the field of psychology and the
idea is you want those really great
things to happen only once in a while
because that's when you'll get the sort
of biggest happiness transition
wow so what you'll feel most is how big
the change was
between where you were and what you then
experience and that's what you then
record
that's exactly right all we're all we're
recording mentally
changes in the transitions and so i i
joke with my students i don't know if
you know this dj khaled song all i do is
win
and i joke with them i was like that
would be the worst for a happy life
because if all you did is win
there's no transitions you're just like
at ceiling oh wait your life would suck
have you seen the twilight zone episode
on this yes exactly oh my gosh
oh my gosh there's there's a criminal
who gets like shot
and then he shows up and he's like a
gambler womanizer
criminal type and he gets shot and dies
okay and he shows up in this place and
this man appears and says hello
you must be you know johnny smith you're
right on time
oh wow what is where am i oh no
don't worry about that okay and he says
oh my gosh there's a pool hall can i go
play pool yeah
and so he he goes and hits the ball and
all the balls get sunk at once
and then he bets on the roulette table
he wins every time
and then all these women come in and
they just throw themselves at them
and it's and he says doc
you know i forgot what his name was but
you know i i don't think i deserve this
place this is you know everything's
going
you know take me to the other place and
this is the other place it's like oh my
god
oh my gosh so there he was with every
single thing
he fought to get risked his life to get
as a criminal and as a thing
now he has it on command and he is the
most miserable person for eternity
ooh yeah so we should talk to you this
is why happiness requires the ups and
downs this is why we require the happy
emotions and the sad emotions right we
want a life filled with both
so maybe the the mantra isn't um more
beers and more babies maybe it's like
split your babies and ration your beers
[Laughter]
thank you nagini for that bit of wisdom
to end the show
oh you're welcome all right we gotta we
gotta stop it there so lori great to
have you on this is a such a fertile
topic
and i'm sure we can find other angles
into this and we're gonna call you back
because you're just up the street in new
haven connecticut and nagin
um always great to have you on here it's
fun
and your book is hilarious and i i
delighted in being a guest on your show
and lori i don't know i have anything to
contribute to your podcast but
if you need i've been happy like my
whole life i think so if you need
something
if you need some a data point call me
okay and by the way for me
i have a lot of hobbies and hobbies
bring they help recenter me when i go
back to them and they
they i reassess where i am in life and
then take them the next step
so anyhow okay guys we're calling it
there this has been star talk cosmic
clearance
the happiness edition i'm neil degrasse
tyson
getting to keep